salut aujourd'hui je suis avec au djé
djé djé djé djé ou autres ghonim ouverte
jeudi vous l'avez vu dans golden
moustache dans le palmashow sur comédie
au théâtre dans d'autres séries les
photos nues ils ont fait tout ça je les
adore déjà formidable je me suis dit
qu'est ce que le qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec rue parce que forcément je
vais essayer de la bleue fait mais je
vais essayer de vous bluffer en même
temps et je me suis dit je veux redire
que je suis fan je suis fan de viol car
oui j'suis fan de fabien olicard et
quand j'ai quand j'ai cherché sur google
je me suis je m'inspire et en reprenant
un peu tout ce que tu as fait tout et je
suis pas allée très loin
je tapais sur google hot money goubert
et je regardais les suggestions que me
proposait google de recherche leurs
suggestions
j'ai eu paul denis gobert copains au 10
downing ouvert couples et aux johnny
guilbert compagnon sa vie sentimentale a
passé les gens c'est un beau minaret
enfin regarder mais c'est tout vraiment
demandé moi directement je vous le
dirais aujourd'hui je vais te proposer
de faire une rencontre mais une
rencontre virtuelle
tu vas rencontrer un mec virtuellement
ça va être ton chéri virtuelle dans une
autre dimension
sache pas ce qu'on va faire pour moi
c'est une galère c'est à dire c'est une
première comme souvent les trucs que je
fais sur la chaîne on va voir ce que ça
donne ou pas j'espère juste y arriver à
un moment donné je j'hésitais soit à te
faire rencontrer quelqu'un virtuellement
est assez d'influencé dans le choix d'un
prénom de personnes soit essayer de les
déduire en fait j'ai pris la décision
que ce serait à mi chemin entre les deux
donc on verra si j'ai bon donc il y aura
trois solutions pro finale soit je me
plante complètement soit j'ai bon que
sur la moitié du prénom soit j'ai tout
prénom d'accord et si c'est tout près
non tu voudras plus j'aime pas la base
j'ai refusé je foncerai voir
toutes tes prochaines représentations
pour essayer de percer et moi même ton
secret j'ai une question est ce que tu
me fais confiance
mais oui bien sûr ok alors ferme les
yeux j'ai très peur mais je sais plus
combien j'ai juste hâte anthouard
complètement ferme les yeux mais je me
protège à pourvoir moi si je fais avec
et je ferme les yeux et on ferme les
yeux je pense que une bonne imagination
alors j'ai envie que juste tu t'imagines
dans une ruelle
c'est la ruelle que tu veux à l'époque
que tu veux comme avait vraiment comme
tu veux dans une ruelle
tout est sécurisé autour de toi y'a rien
de spécial et on est plutôt en fin de
journée néanmoins s'il ya des enfants de
lampadaires ils sont allés mais s'il ya
des fenêtres sont ouvertes elles sont
animées et c est au bout de cette ruelle
sur la gauche il ya un bar et se barrent
la devanture du bar est un petit peu
faire tu vois tu vas devant le bar tu me
reconnais donc c'est un partage à vue
d'accords et tu vas rentrer à
l'intérieur et maintenant cela c'est toi
qui va m'expliquer où elle comptoir est
ce qu'il est en face de toi ou auch à
droite explique moi un peu comme en
effet ce bar alors
le bar est en face à droite en fait on
est contre le mur enfin oui bob est ce
que j'ai à dire et j'ai en face à droite
et il ya plein de table tout autour
voilà en face de moi c'est à une sorte
de grand rectangle et vit avec le
comptoir qui va vers le fond
comme s'il y avait un couloir ok
d'accord je commençais à noter des
petites choses - mon côté je suis sûr
que tu ouvres sur un visage il ya marqué
prénom sur votre visage
c'est un c'est un serveur ou serveuse
herria quelqu'un comtois et à une
serveuse dans salle et c'est un homme au
comptoir
c'est un homme au comptoir d'accord ok
tu va regarder cet homme là et
j'aimerais que tu imagines qu'il est pas
très sympa un peu agressive qui parlent
mal tu vois d'accord tu va discuter avec
lui tu juste tu lève la main pour pour
commander est en fête et répond oui bah
chacun son tour
vous n'avez pas cinq minutes qu'est ce
que tu lui réponds toi est ce que c'est
moi
cette excuse willy claes marcher dessus
car c'est un oui parce que chez surprise
d'accord quand je suis pas surprise
quand je suis préparée je suis armé mais
quand je ne suis pas je m'excuse
ok ok du coup il ya quelqu'un qui vient
d'aborder qui vient te parler pourtant
un beau jeune homme
en tout cas c'est complètement ton style
dans cette réalité là et il se met à
parler avec toi la pluie et du beau
temps parle du soleil du temps qu'il
fait et de ce genre de choses d'accord
et en plus ils commencent à discuter
avec toi de choses et d'autres et du
fait qu'il n'aime pas trop le serveur il
a vu comment es tu avais parlé c'est
inadmissible il est pas très sympa avec
toi ullmann
tu vois ça lui plaît pas des masses est
et du coup lui va te payer un verre sur
sa bouteille qui est la salanque
attendra pas d'accord et toi tu vois
bien quelque chose qu'il se passe
attends je téléphone qui sonne en même
temps je veux tu vois bien quelque chose
qui se passait et que ça va être le
début d'une grande relation virtuelle
parce que tout ça c'est mental et bien
sûr et tu lui demande son prénom et du
coup ils te donnent de son prénom ce
shérif virtuel comment s'appelle-t-il
avoue je te dise
t'inquiète pas on va pouvoir le dire moi
je les marque est certes c'est vrai j'ai
marqué quelque chose ici donc là je te
le dis ouais il s'appelle constants il
s'appelle constants ouais c'est marrant
qui s'appelle constants j'ai besoin de
réaliser ce que moi j'avais décrit juste
là sur ce papier est elle donne ici même
dans des mains et tu peux ouvrir les
yeux et j'avais exactement marqué
consistant non ça va pas du tout mais
enfin tu es tu va m'expliquer quand même
alors non ça tombe bien que tu le dises
vidéo qui s'en fait pour bluffer la
personne qui vient pour les bleus fait
aussi puisque je passe mon temps à
expliquer des choses j'ai envie de temps
en temps de bluffer tout le monde non
mais c'est même pas un prénom parce que
je me connais personne qui s'appelle
comme ça moi et puis surtout j'ai changé
d'avis à la dernière seconde alors ça
j'avais pour décider antoine et je me
souviens il faut un prénom est très
compliqué c'était antoine a dit cool
parce qu'antoine va pas être possible
quand est ce que je me suis dit je
trouve un truc un peu plus compliqué
pour le pour le challenge et ça me
tuerait choix du souffle je n'ai aucun
secret pour cet homme alors j'ai décidé
quelque chose maintenant joffrin interne
et à tous ceux qui viennent ouais c'est
un trip que les abonnés de la chaîne
donc voici un carnet reçu un cadeau à
marseille pour trouver un tu pourras
dire oui il a trouvé à temps je regarde
si ma famille la vraie solution du truc
ils habitent et demi tous les prénoms et
tous les prêts mais il ya toujours et
non non j'ai juste à la dernière saison
qui en est fait c'est pas vrai mais
s'éclater en train de lancer sa chaîne à
toi youtube oui j'ai lancé ma chaîne de
vie chrome bientôt ouais je suis
contente ça fait peur s'appellera
comment la chaîne alors la chaîne ça
sera mon nom parce qu'elle est déjà à
créer que je sais pas comment on crée un
autre compte
la première vidéo sera pas encore sorti
mais vous pouvez déjà vous abonner en
anticipation fait ça c'est chouette
exactement tu sais que ya pierre cros
qui a fait ça pour greg romano il ya
quelques jours
ouais là où deux jours et greg du coup
lui c'est dans quelques mois qu'ils vont
sortir c'était pour tourner au youtube
space à paris elle donc il y as besoin
d'abord naturellement sur la chaîne 10
59 3 55 me alors c'est bon ce ne sera
pas le cas là autant sur ma chaîne et
déjà toutes les playlists de tout ce que
j'ai fait et ça c'est pas mal donc je
vous mets le lien vers la chaîne de mode
et même si le nouveau projet bague en or
sortie il ya toutes les playlists avec
tout ce que oda fervent et ça c'est
mortel vous pouvez déjà vous délecter de
ceux ci merci beaucoup
qu'est ce que j'avais d'autres à dire
avec le mental box est toujours une
vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures
chaouch